[Music]
hello world
it's time for a thought experiment
[Music]
let's imagine the cold war went another
way
after the nazis surrendered
[Music]
the soviet union flexed its muscles and
asserted its imperial might
from tokyo to tacoma
memorials to the fatherland popped up
around the globe
this would be the washington monument
this could have been your morning
commute
[Music]
and now let's fast forward these were
the first semiconductors
this is your keyboard this was the first
ibm computer
this is facebook headquarters
this is silicon valley
well that didn't happen but in modern
russia
it's easy to get confused with an extra
helping of spycraft
technology here developed a world apart
from silicon valley
and that didn't change when the soviet
union collapsed
[Applause]
25 years later russia has copied large
parts of the web
the rest of us know and love they built
a russian internet and with new laws
cooked up by the kremlin
and rubber stamped in moscow more and
more
it's a sovereign internet like anything
sovereign
it needs walls to protect it and virtual
walls are going up today
to find out exactly how the russian web
works
there was only one thing to do
i had to upload myself
now that i'm inside i'll meet a tech
oligarch
travel to siberia to dive into a
surprising
and very remote startup scene
and test the latest in facial
recognition software
let's enter this parallel universe
together
on this episode of hello world
[Music]
[Applause]
silicon valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world
but it's being challenged like never
before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet
making things that will blow your mind
my name is ashley vance i'm an author
and journalist
and i'm on a quest to find the most
innovative tech creations
and meet the beautiful freaks behind
them hello
in moscow over the past decade the
tsar's gilded churches and monuments to
the proletariat
have given way to the symbols of modern
russia
[Music]
opulent capitalist towers that poke
through the clouds
at the heart of this is where i met
dimitri grisham hello dmitry
he's the co-founder of mailroo group and
one of only a few people
east of helsinki who can drive me to the
office in his own tesla
i organized a drive for all my employees
like
three thousand people because they want
all to test how accelerate
dimitri sits atop a russian tech empire
and runs an investment fund for robotics
with its roots in silicon valley
that doesn't make you want to move there
you have so much going on here
maybe one day never say never right
[Music]
dmitry's tried to copy silicon valley
culture here in moscow
where mailroo group operates two instant
messaging networks
a search engine a price comparison
website
and a ton of online games
they also control the three largest
russian social networking sites
the biggest one is vk the facebook
knockoff
dimitri and mailroot group took over vk
in 2014
after its founder pavel durov refused to
reveal information about ukrainian
activists to the kremlin
durov lost his company and now lives in
self-imposed exile
overall then do you consider the russian
tech scene competitive
yes and you know it's interesting things
that it's very few countries where
local players are very strong and
comparing for example with china this
internet is
fully closed we have facebook instagram
all kind of
western players and still pretty
successful so i think we have
pretty pretty tough competition
to get a taste of the high life of a
tech oligarch
[Music]
dimitri and i headed for a bite to eat
at the tallest restaurant in europe
354 meters above the moscow traffic
dimitri grew up programming on computers
that plugged into soviet tvs
but things really took off when he
enrolled at moscow state technical
university
in 1995. and the same year uh microsoft
announced windows 95
this famous song from rolling stone
started me up
[Music]
next two years i tried to write my own
windows
it's so expensive windows maybe you can
just cheap cheap version
so sitting writing it but after some
time
i say ah okay no it's too hard
[Music]
he might have failed to rewrite the
world's most popular operating system
but he did stumble on the copycat
business model
that became mailroo group
[Music]
it's hard to imagine now but in 2004
only nine percent of russians had
internet access
what was the russian government's
assessment of the technology industry
they didn't know that they exist that
all changed in 2012.
russia had become the biggest internet
market in europe
some people use the web to complain
about putin
and organize protests against his
reelection
the kremlin responded in full orwellian
glory
with a series of laws that allows them
to flag opposition
sites as extremists and blacklist them
ever since it's been hard to tell where
the vlad web begins
and ends i think in the us the idea
is that the russian government and the
tech companies are just
intertwined if you follow the law you're
okay
definitely the laws became more
complicated right and sometimes it's
definitely the way how to interpret the
law
those new laws passed this year would
make edward snowden weep into his bush
they demand all sites russians can
access move their servers here
including the googles and facebooks of
the world
once on russian soil they have to store
six months worth of data
about people's every move online and
then give the kremlin access
russian companies like melrou protested
they said these measures would take a
ridiculous amount of storage space
but they obviously lost american
companies have said there's no way
they're moving to russia
so now their criminal enterprise is here
and that's how you build a sovereign
internet
when we grow our business our concept
was that
internet was the global system no border
at all
user everywhere can connect to
everywhere data can be migrating
everything so it's really was
global phenomena but now i think that
fundamental global shift everywhere that
you have country you have borders and
inside these borders you have different
kind of rules
how data is moving how connectivity is
moving who can connect to what
who can do what so
we're not having like global internet
we're having some kind of some
global internet but uh a lot of like
local internets
and for me this is big set uh in terms
of
change
it's hard to wrap your head around just
how big siberia
is and even harder to understand how
most people live here
so to get acquainted i found another
dimitri
this one a real natural-born siberian
man
to initiate me into the ways of the
russian wilderness
[Music]
i'm sure this is a good idea right
perfect idea
a trip to the banya is an ancient and
some would say
masochistic russian bonding ritual it
consists of three delightful steps
okay ashley inferno is ready for
entrance
step one nearly have heat stroke
[Music]
step two shrinkage
step three get whacked
what does this do keep silent please
when he's not beating other men with
birch branches my new russian friend
dimitri
is a philosophy professor here in akadem
goradak
that's my destination a small town hours
by plane from moscow
and about 30 minutes outside russia's
third largest city
novosibirsk
nikita khrushchev's government declared
60 years ago
that this would be the siberian home of
the soviet academy of sciences
built from nothing in the middle of a
remote tiger forest
that stretches halfway around the planet
academy it was the first soviet
technopolis
and it was a good opportunity for many
young scientists
how has it changed over the last 40
years in comparison to soviet
time we have not so much
opportunities but we love our place
because it's wonderful 40 institutes a
real scientific community
toast
what will the toast here no beauty to
the enemies of
science cheers
soaked swatted steaming and having
proven my loyalty to science
i was ready to explore academic
the soviets hid temples to science in
the trees
with shrines to match like this one
to all the mice they sacrificed on the
altar of genetic research
inside the nuclear physics institute it
feels like i walked under the set of dr
strangelove
these analog dials laser contraptions
and miles of metal pipes were all built
to push nuclear science to its summit
replicating the sun's power by smashing
atoms together
people have been chasing fusion for
decades
what's still encouraging and exciting
about this field the scientific problem
is like a huge mountain
and for 60 years people are trying to
get to the top
everything around the base of the
mountain is like a
trash dump bodies
and stuff but you can imagine
the results you can achieve when you get
to the top
professor alexei beklumichev researches
something called
open trap mechanisms to encourage fusion
this is also useful in order to make
plasma thrusters
for space ships
at the moment it is just an idea
the soviet government attracted
brilliant minds like alexei's to siberia
with spacious apartments in the kind of
prestige they could only get
in a town founded as a utopian
nerdocracy
[Applause]
but when the soviet union fell so did
the walls keeping scientists here
and many of them bolted to work at ibm
or mit
or boeing for those who stayed
the utopia has lost its luster
over time the difference in pay
between scientists and say bus drivers
went in favor of bus drivers
if you are overworked and without pay
you you want to go elsewhere
ten years ago the russian government
decided it needed to hit refresh on the
entire town
to pull siberian science out of its
post-soviet slump
they're turning to a new generation of
engineers
plucked from the taiga to lead the way
and one of the most successful so far is
dimitri tribitsin
yes another dimitri today akadem gradoc
is changing now there are not only
scientists but
there are also a lot of companies more
like startups
yeah more like startups today dimitri's
the poster boy for a siberian startup
success story
this company theon started off making
king-size air filters
for hospitals and other businesses and
now they have their eyes on china
tion's success belongs to dimitri but
it's built on a blueprint drawn up by
the russian government
his headquarters is on a sprawling
government-funded campus
called academ park with this crazy tower
in the middle of it
not recommended if you have a fear of
heights
this place is a prime example of one of
the big ideas in russian tech
a cradle to grave genius factory
[Music]
across the country they start them young
with a strictly uniform education
heavy on math and science they pull the
best out of siberia
and send them down the street to nova
sabirsk state university
from there they used to funnel their
brains to places like the nuclear
institute
but now that that's a bit retro many of
them end up here
in the tech tower here it's like someone
visited a few silicon valley startups
punched the copy button ran it through
google translate and then hit
paste in the middle of siberia here's
the living wall
only here it's dead here's the
makerspace
and the 3d printed putin here's the gym
only it's siberia so it comes with bear
hello innovation
[Music]
over the past few years russia has honed
the art of turning computer science
nerds
into ai building geniuses
to test one of the most powerful and
controversial pieces of ai infused
software ever built
i've traveled to the heart of moscow and
it's famed gorky park
[Music]
just five years ago this was a decaying
soviet relic
today it's buzzing with people on wheels
and friendly russian faces
and my goal here is to find a few
hi would you mind if i take a photo of
your
face i'm trying to do a little bit of an
experiment can i take a photo of your
face
i just take a photo of you and then see
we see if it can
find your vk profile you might find me
on facebook
it doesn't work on facebook yet because
they don't let you search the database
find face is an android app that lets
you take a picture of a new friend
or a complete stranger in a few seconds
it scans all 250 million photos from vk
the russian facebook knockoff and then
finds a match
all right let's see what happens moment
of truth here we go
[Music]
oh it's me oh it's me
yes it's me and your hair is so
different in the photo
definitely find me first yeah so it
works
yeah it's really cool do you think it's
strange
it's strange but cool you like some girl
and you take a photo and you can find
her
and text her or something yeah so you
you guys like it i wouldn't
like this so if i forgot
if this is my son or not i can be check
it
with my phone
[Music]
this year find face took its algorithm
to america
for something called the mega face
challenge
there it beat google and a lot of other
face spotting software
to find out how they did it nice to meet
you nice to meet you
i went to meet the algorithm's creator
at the office of his company
and tech do you mind showing me how the
technology works a little bit
can we try me so these are my
russian brethren my cousins
[Laughter]
is it ranked in order by who they think
looks the most
like this is like a 60 year old with a
machine gun
another guy with a gun i want to show
you something else
why am i a bear
so the similarity is very low but yes
albert thinks that
there are some some similarities
sometimes it's difficult to
say why neural network works this way
but
but it works
arction programmed a neural network that
approaches face finding differently than
others
he fed it thousands of image matches and
after about six months of training
voila it learned to read faces
essentially you don't even know what the
neural network is
seeing in the beginning neural network
gives
random answers and the accuracy is close
to
zero and during training if everything
goes well the accuracy
grows if you can efficiently find the
exact person among
huge data sets it opens a lot more
interesting use cases
like for example you can search for
criminals in real life among
all the street cameras in the city
are we creeped out yet maybe we should
be
entech has already signed a contract
with the moscow city police
though archum won't talk about it and he
says they already have agreements with
other law enforcement agencies both
inside
and outside russia it's easy to imagine
what the fbi
or its russian counterpart the fsb could
do with this kind
of technology so it's a little bit
controversial right because
anyone can identify you now out of the
crowd i would say that the implications
of this
very scary i think fs bear is
searching us right there i'm saying like
companies here are big companies
corporations and governments definitely
know
everything about you but for random
people
this makes it much easier you have to be
careful
if you go it outside in the street or in
your facebook
or any other social network you've done
it
you're open to to be recognized
[Music]
this idea that you're not anonymous when
you walk the street
anymore somebody can just snap your
photo and identify
who you are you must have thought about
that when you were developing
the technology when we were developing
we
were thinking only about accuracy and
how cool it is
but priority finish when you have
smartphones with you because they can
track all the information about you
it's a battle between technology and
privacy
my personal guess that technology will
win
[Music]
on the outskirts of moscow you'll find
skokova
where the hope is that other startups
like find face will come to life
this is one of a series of startup
cities that russia is building to
increase the might and reach of its
sovereign tech
to an outsider like me the depth of
russia's state influence on companies
feels flat out backward and wrong it's
hard to imagine a true tech utopia
springing up in a place like this edward
snowden
yes he's somewhere out there
would say the u.s has its eyes
everywhere too
whether you're on this internet or that
one
you're never alone anymore
up next on hello world i travel to
chile's atacama desert
to go hunting for the origins of the
universe
and find myself with the help of a
shaman
and some low-tech frog poison